hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 19 video we
totally got a look at sabotage so we got
to talk all about this you have to ask
yourself at the end of the episode who
is the one person that Caitlin would
trust immediately no matter how evil
he'd seemed in what he put them all
through she just instantly says without
wasting a beat what do you need me to do
I am totally happy to do whatever evil
thing you want me to do to team flash
and my former friends there are only a
couple people in the multiverse that
she'd be willing to do that for never
before has my Twitter feed been so
unanimous in the person that they think
thats avatar is so we'll talk about that
but there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so working through
top 10 WTF in comic book Easter eggs
there were a couple comic book Easter
eggs and a lot of people were wondering
about the flash ring because of all the
future Flash stuff and there's a lot of
mounting evidence that Barry or a
version of Barry could be Savitt are so
there were a couple things that pointed
to that in this episode so working
through top 10 number 10 Barry makes the
calculations he's going to 2020 for the
exact day on the future newspaper where
it says flash vanishes in crisis so the
weird thing is that when he gets to this
day in the future there is no crisis
it's been like this this escape from New
York if you guys are big John Carpenter
fans it's like the Escape from New York
version of Central City
the Rogues have taken over it because
captain cold and heat waves I've been on
legends of tomorrow this year its mere
master and top that have risen to the
top of the pile so they've been ruling
over Central City in Barry's absence
because he's been sidelined as we learn
later in his grief but number 9 I love
the way they opened the episode with
it's snowing outside and snowing inside
STAR Labs they start outside Barry and
irises window and it's snowing I'll
explain why it's snowing in a second
there's actually a funny reason for that
because when they filmed this episode in
Vancouver there was actually a really
bad snowstorm the same thing happened
when they filmed the last episode too
they've been having really bad storms so
they just had to work it into the
episode but it totally worked
because inside STAR Labs winter has come
and Caitlin is going full-blown killer
frost on the rest of the team so the
whole thing here is that she knows
exactly what's happening she
conscious of what she's doing but she
says I don't want to do the right thing
I want to let the bad version of myself
out I don't want to be Kaitlin anymore
so there's a couple gaps in the logic
like they haven't really explained what
it is about the killer frost part of
herself it's so freeing to Kaitlyn like
what is it that she's suppressing about
herself when she's Kaitlin
usually the killer frost part of her is
just the expression of all the things
that she keeps locked up inside of her
like all the anger all the hate all the
negative emotions because the last two
seasons Kaitlyn's been a pretty happy
character with the exception of season
one Kaitlyn because Ronnie had died so
we will talk all about the dead version
of Ronnie in a second because he's
actually very important to this episode
but number seven Barry travels to the
future with the help of Wally doing the
exact same trick that he did during
season two when he sent the reverse
flash back to his future time you really
just need two speedsters to run fast
enough to create enough force to open
the portal to the future Barry should
logically be able to do it by himself
but I think the reason they did it this
way on the TV show is just to make it a
little bit harder otherwise why wouldn't
you just go to the Future all the time
they don't want to make it an easy thing
you could just do at the drop of a hat
so Barry gets to escape from New York
central city and immediately gets his
ass handed to him by future mirror
master and future top who have had eight
years to rule the city and grow more
powerful so they're literally more
powerful because they've had all those
years to hone their powers but they're
figuratively more powerful in the city
because the flash has been dormant and
they just run rampant
so the Rogues rule and Barry goes on his
mission to try and find out what's going
on and where all his friends are so
number six he runs into Cisco and starts
to learn what's happened to everyone in
the past eight years
why is everybody broken up why isn't the
team together why does everything look
like it's gone to in Cisco explains
to him that Barry just completely broke
inside and then we get the rest of the
explanation from future flash so he
explains that what happened is is that
after iris died he completely committed
himself to stopping Savatage and he was
successful but he did it at the expense
of his friends and family so they became
the collateral damage so at the end of
the day Savitt are still one so that's
why he's still broken inside and
depressed
because he was able to stops avatar but
everybody's so stuck in their grief and
all the terrible things that have
happened to them
it has driven them apart and they can't
handle it so number five our version of
Barry's mission becomes more about
bringing team flash back together in the
future in being this beacon of hope in
their time of darkness and that's a lot
of foreshadowing about the stuff that's
going to come for him in the past like
he still has a long way to go before he
defeats avatar and his secret weapon
isn't the Speed Force the fact that he's
a speedster it's his ability to generate
hope and to make people around him feel
better to bring people together so the
episode is kind of a reminder for Barry
in the past that that's what he needs to
focus on more than anything in reminding
future Barry's that he also needs to do
that too so they leave it in a really
good place but all those final scenes
that they had together you know one for
all all for one we're on our way to
becoming a family again was just a way
of telling you that Barry wasn't there
to find out about Savitt are it was to
find out more about himself and
reconnect with his family so we got to
talk about all the WTF so number four
the things that happened to all the team
flash members so right off the bat the
worst thing that probably happened was
Wally getting his spine broken hunter
zolomon style so everybody was like
maybe Wally's avatar I think we probably
learned definitively that he is not but
he's still in such a state of shock by
what he saw the night that he fought
Savitt are and loss that he hasn't said
anything about it since then so whatever
he saw underneath the avatars mask
shocked him to his very core but there's
also the emotional trauma of getting
your spine broken that's also probably
made him catatonic too so of all the
team flash members Wally is probably the
worse off Caitlyn is stuck in prison and
she explains all the things that savat
are told to her
he helped me embrace my true self in
what she's saying is embrace her killer
frost self and he sort of clarifies that
at the end of the episode when he says I
want to help you make sure they Caitlyn
never comes back number three just
because it's such a big deal had to give
it its own WTF Cisco losing both of his
hands in the scene that they show where
he loses them is a continuation of the
seems that he vibed in the future back
during episode six
when Caitlin was first starting to
become killer frost this
scene right here
so that is totally messed up and you
totally forgive Cisco for trapping Barry
in the future even though you kind of
figure it out pretty fast like Cisco
probably did something to keep him from
going to the past but all is forgiven
and danielle Panabaker has teased that
because we have an episode coming up
whereby fights killer frost is that
we'll see a different version of that
play out so the idea is that our version
of Cisco isn't that tragic he's not
going to lose his hands at the end of
the year so something is going to be
different about that fight that they
have she also teased that her killer
frost costume is going to be a slightly
different version of the one that we see
in this scene from the future so little
things are changing even though like the
really big things like iris dying are
still on the board they haven't fixed
that yet but number two we learn about
Tracy brand the scientists in the past
who's going to help bury but future bury
gives them the hard drive that hopefully
will speed it along like here's all of
our research that took her four years to
finish maybe she can use this to make
her device much faster before iris dies
so we just watched flash episode 19
episode 23 the finale is the same day
that future Barry said that iris dies so
that's just a way of saying that this
moment here is going to be happening in
the final episode of season 3 and I know
there's a whole bunch of talk about
what's going on with the finale we can
talk about that in bonus videos because
there's still so much between now and
then but before I talk about my number
one how about that future Barry costume
I know some of you are too hot on it
because of the gold highlights and the
giant gold belt but it's a brighter
color of red something that everybody
has been asking for for a long time
Grant Gustin tease hey you know isn't it
time for Barry to get a new suit that
was the suit that he was talking about
in Cisco even says the 2017 version of
the white emblem meaning that they'll
probably change the emblem again in the
future so we'll see a slightly different
version of his costume at least by
season four but we got to talk about
number one Savitt are coming out of the
costume and revealing himself to Caitlin
so the thing about this is that he
doesn't speak when he steps out you kind
of see the way that it opens it's like
this big tech suit
he has these cool black leather pants is
just meant to show you that he's a
normal person underneath the costume but
the thing that's most telling is the
look on kaitlin's face because she's
been so evil for this entire episode is
that when she witnesses who he is she
just completely jumps on board in an
instant and there are only a few people
that she cares about that deeply it
would make her respond in that way and
even though there are a number of
possibilities for who's avatar could be
unanimously like all over my Twitter
feed spammed with the name Ronnie
Raymond so let's just speculate about
how it could potentially be Ronnie one
he would have to have Speed Force
ability is given to him by the
Philosopher's Stone and he said that he
was the first person to get speed so
there's a lot of explaining to do
they're like how could Ronnie be the
person that got speed if he was born in
present-day and he died back during
season one there'd have to be some crazy
explanation for that because this season
has been all about Barry
letting other people sacrifice
themselves for him in him being super
selfish so the message this season is
that Barry needs to take ownership of
his mistakes and be true to his family
that's why everybody's thinking that at
the end of this season
he might go into the Speed Force to pay
for his Speed Force crimes so that just
one potential for who saboteur could be
so even though Ronnie is a solid pick
that is why I am still stuck on Barry as
Savitt are just because you know of all
the people that Caitlin would trust it's
Barry and Ronnie
and it just make more sense for the
narrative right now based on the
evidence that we have that the mystery
person that they keep teasing out like
who it's avatar who is savat are you
need to know who he is well who do you
need to know better than yourself know
thyself so let me know in the comments
who do you think's avatar is who stepped
out of that costume at the end so what's
going to happen is is all posed to do
flash trailer video tomorrow we'll talk
all about this avatar stuff this is
going to take us a couple videos to work
through but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Roy Harper please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here to learn all
about the live-action Teen Titans TV
show that's written by Geoff Johns
coming next year and you can click here
for brand new Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video